there's a really interesting kind of
reef shuffling i guess we would call it
of right-wing media i'm not going to
spend a ton of time on this today and
those of you who have been watching
listening to recent episodes you already
know about this
it's not actually happening but there's
a growing narrative that fox news has
abandoned donald trump now
the reality is much more measured it's
not that fox has abandoned trump and
it's not that fox is completely
brown-nosing trump there's sort of a
spectrum on fox news but fox news is
doing the best possible thing for their
business with their news coverage now
the nighttime opinion people
are still sucking up to trump as much as
they ever were even to some degree the
fox and friends people are as well but
fox news is setting itself up to be able
to kind of pull the escape of the um
eject button
and go to someone else if indeed trump
is not the republican nominee in 2024
and maybe there's even a slight
preference for someone else but
regardless they're still
staying
keeping options open
not wanting to lose access to trump
newsmax is playing up the war between
trump and fox news and of course they
would it's to their advantage if you are
targeting
the most aggressively sycophantic
elements of the fox news audience
they are the hardcore magats and
one of the things that might steer them
to your network is to convince them that
fox news has abandoned your president or
whatever and so they're really pla
playing it up and they are mentioning at
any opportunity that it's been a hundred
days since trump was on fox news
and coming up shadow band why former
president trump hasn't appeared on the
major news network in over 100 days
that's fox news what's going on there we
discussed after the break that's a very
explosive story for newsmax why has it
been a hundred days since uh trump
appeared on fox news it's all
self-serving and self-interested that's
all it is yes fox may have a slight
preference for someone else yes fox
wants to set itself up to have access to
whoever is the nominee in 2024 for the
republicans but they're not actually
turning on trump in any serious way then
they brought on some expert
i don't even know who this guy is and
again the topic is about
um
trump and praising newsmax and
it's the cup newsmax is increasingly
covering
trump not being on fox news if not ahead
um and and so it would seem they would
want to track this and he could announce
any day now now there's some people who
say he's not going to do that to after
midterms but we don't know that it
defies common logic how do you talk
about the election for president without
talking about donald trump and you think
they're not talking about them they're
trying to avoid him i mean he may appear
sooner or later but they're still going
to try their best to ignore him you know
it's interesting because you know you
you mentioned that now this is
interesting at the bottom of the screen
it says murdoch's move away from trump
to be more establishment the idea being
that these are decisions being made not
necessarily by rupert murdoch personally
although maybe he's involved i believe i
don't remember which of rupert murdoch's
kids
there's like uh lachlan murdoch and all
these different i don't i don't know
which one of them is highly involved at
fox news right now one of them is
they're framing it as a personal thing i
think that this primarily continues to
be a business and access thing but but
we'll learn more about that i'm sure as
we get beyond the midterms max what what
you are so happy that we do as as i know
many of our viewers are as i am as well
that we let our viewers decide and we
present them with the information and
okay if you agree great if you don't you
don't but even former president trump
has uh lauded newsmax
certainly has and for good reason we we
give him that that
vehicle to at least speak to what he
speaks to and again let our viewers
decide i mean you know we have an
intelligent viewership as i thought the
times and the post did too but no that's
not true i i would guess we're finding
out differently well it's your saying
that the new york times of all people
are the ones that come out and say you
know what that's what that's what got me
there's a there there yeah yeah there's
a bear there brian anderson normally
it's us telling obvious lies but every
once in a while the new york times will
come out and say something so that's
what's going on newsmax coverage is
increasingly
covering trump
not being covered
by fox news in as favorable terms as
maybe they would like to see and again
these are all business ploys this
everybody wants to chalk this up and th
this is sometimes what
i'll meet people
from outside the media space like most
people i meet are outside the media
space even though because of the space
i'm in i know a lot of media people as
well the people in the media space get
it
but then i'll talk to people outside the
media space
and they will understandably believe all
these narratives fox news has taken this
perspective for moral reasons and then
newsmax has this other belief in
reaction whatever yet to some degree
that goes on but most of these networks
and channels it's not like the david
pakman show where it's just there's no
posturing it's just my opinion that's it
if there's a story i'm not interested in
i just don't cover it if there's a story
i'm interested in i cover it and i just
give you my opinion there's no posturing
it might be good for quote clicks or it
might be bad for clicks with fox news
and newsmax and whatever it's all being
primarily uh analyzed through the lens
of what does this do
for
our viewership and fox news right now
has made the calculation probably a
correct one that they need to find kind
of straddle the fact that there is uh a
res a negative
uh there's a repelling going on by some
in the right wing of trump
and trump might not be the nominee in
2024 he might not even run
and so they need to be ready for that to
credibly be able to
rejoin the establishment for lack of a
better term but they also need to keep
the door open for trump that's their
calculation it's nothing about ideology
although there might be ideology that's
part of it newsmax
i guess they probably do love trump but
i'm sure there are people who work at
newsmax who are kind of see trump as a
buffoon
but their calculation is playing up
the war between trump and fox news is
good for our viewership and it's good
for our positioning and it might
ingratiate us with trump even further so
that he will appear on the network more
talk about us more etc that's what's
going on don't don't think it's anything
else